here we go Walking Dead the final season
five years ago I played this game and it
was huge for me and this channel it was
such a journey and yeah it wasn't that
exciting all the way through here we are
at the end at the Walking Dead the final
season of course of course I'm gonna
play this I have to see it through man
some stuff you just have to see through
literally what I just said good job
Felix what do you guys think are you
excited so it came out today I'm ok so
we got four episodes oh this is making
me anxious what is gonna happen to
climate clothes start episode let's do
this let's freakin do this guy's my 9
year olds smash like if you're excited
for this plate there let's do dad
started walking I was small and alone
oh yeah so small small is a man named
Lee became my protector
[Music]
my man
they always go for the ankles men
protect your ankle he's protected other
people too but not their ankles but he
couldn't save everyone because of the
okay so I remember this it was so long
ago but I saved Carly which didn't
matter cuz she just died anyway everyone
living were just as dangerous as the
dead a woman in our group named
oh that's bad word and then she just
couldn't cope yeah yeah she betrayed me
took the life that li saved okay that
made me super angry we left her behind I
remember is that you shot her you shot
Carly which I deliberately same on the
side of the road you best not come back
taught me how to survive he protected me
as long as he could but he got bit we
don't need to hear this again don't not
even in the end he was still teaching
[Music]
keep your hair short o pioneers if I
still remembered just not worth the risk
I'm not gonna cry I'm a man now
not some manchild at the end he made one
final request
a shovel he asked me to shoot him and I
did
so we're going through all the choice
group after that broken people running
from their past there was a woman who
gave birth to a boy named Alvin jr. AJ
he made it but the mom didn't I remember
this season she was good I did like I
started to take care of him I don't care
about AJ that much I'm sorry I know Jane
left AJ in the snow we thought he was
gone forever
that was the last straw for Kenny and
without Lee around I had to make the
call
technically if you got the ending here's
the thing I played it - I played it
twice I wanted to see all the ending so
I think I what I did first time was that
I shot Kenny and then the second time I
hit Jane died and I really liked both
endings I kind of want to keep Kenny
alive no I have to
don't make me make the same choice twice
Ola doula Dolph king kelana cough cough
alone a binky born all a doula Dolph
okay Kenny
AJ was alive Jane hit him to make a
point knowing what they'd done
it was a nice ending anyway I stayed we
can until decided we were better
together for AJ sake
I like everything else I like that
ending don't just you guys need to stop
tonight each one carries new frontier
I thought we'd found something that
worked but I was wrong again they took
Jeff from me said I was too young to
take care of him you're only nine you
can't take care of no child well I
fought for AJ I remember oh I fought
back oh she's spitting I wasn't strong
enough I searched for a long time it's
all coming back now just when I gave up
hope
I found him
we're searching together now
or a place we can call home is that her
now only Jay has
she's still growing up and I'll protect
you
life just like me did for me
radda radda right how you cast ready let
me hear it yeah it's cool I'm glad
that's a cool way to give a flashback of
like what happened it's interesting how
much more I remember season one cuz
season one was just so good
Nessie's do is I it's still good and
these three is like I don't know about
this seems a far better make up for
right
that's all I'm saying I'm glad they're
ending it and I really hope this will be
good like I I know I keep saying it for
like it means so much to me man they
look like they improved the graphics a
lot
or do you think hey she can drive now
use s to adjust the rear rear there he
is my man
Ephraim boy oh he can talk now doing
their goofball petunia we got bullets
well don't it's getting on my nerves
I don't like Goose ball
you don't like the name I'm too big for
it now by shitbird someone's all grown I
guess you're all grown up now
yep let me drive I'm not letting you
drive the ice kind of look like ice from
doles you know it's almost like they're
popping out and they're so glassy it's
wrong it's making me uncomfortable
holy
all right whatever he we got some
broccoli and you want to empirically
that's not a totally Liza broccoli get
out of here all right here Alvin jr.
it's me disco broccoli word on the
street is an image about me is that true
do you want to eat me come on Clem I
can't eat a toy
Oh God man my feelings are hurt my
stomach hurt
hmm sassy okay all right this is epic
how about this practice your reading but
I don't wanna it'll take your mind off
your stomach the heat oven
place cream
Nilla beans into a saucepan and bring to
a boy on second thought never mind
that's only gonna make you hungrier yeah
that really made me starving there way
he described the words I just felt my
whole mouth what about you
go for it we'll find something else soon
I believe you just eat the potatoes
I like the background I don't know if I
like the characters you need to tip me
speaking EPT
okay all right okay I'm sorry I'm so
sorry I didn't know
here we go a super high contrast it's
crazy how different it looks
a radda radda ray we gonna do it think
so
looks clear let me guess
it's not we're doing it all right so
remember
shankam friendly ring valve no
trespassing what is this there's a bowel
what's with all the toys grab the bar
we need water - I guess we'll bring the
toy mr. radish ratas zap alright alright
array find ring let's find some food I
wonder how old the actress of Clementine
was when she started did they use the
same one or did she grow up with the
character it's been 5 years after all
right all right
yeah there's food everywhere here as
everyone knows there's I can run as well
AJ stay back
yes stay back AJ like Clementine deal
with this oh yeah oh yeah what you got
oh oh yeah cute
Zingo bazinga is what Sheldon sassy and
I'm bringing it back everybody it's such
a good catchphrase I need help
let's just keep going all right AJ don't
mess it up
AJ monster trap it's not a trap what a
sweet on it don't like you AJ fun you
get in the tire and someone pushes you
so that we go really high I wanna try
yeah exactly thank you
all right you get one point for that
common AJ 1/2 a point don't like you
aging
good thing I have a prior she's not even
using it right the wrong end what do we
do inside a new place we listen for
monsters after that come on you remember
back foot Danny that's besito
inside a new place check Germanwings
that's right it's clearly gonna be
people in there AJ he's always listening
has he heard what I said about him oh
hey guys welcome come on in take a seat
all tied up they can't get us family
feud is about to get on come home sit
down relax have a snack no he can't
we're waiting for Jeff Spacely to fire
this was
security door who can't pry that open I
know you're hungry I am to find
something I promise all right
enter the ticket boo I'm gonna kill him
oh it's trying to touch my nipples get
out of here disgusting hey hey don't
touch me what happening just stab on
them in the back of the head really
should not be that hard
Oh they wrote her no this alone this is
what we wanted name to just sit
losers how they drank wausau poison did
they give up now they just drank poison
this world together holding hands in
their own home
well we have a home we'll see all right
you guys just stab them in I would 100%
stab them in the head just let that be
known name it's risky
if there's a choice way through that
door I will always stab in the head
let's be smart you don't need to tell me
that you schmuck stab them in the head
problem solved don't like someone just
kidding all right it's not an easy Oh
s80 oh okay I like it a lie that's very
nice this family had taste
I mean who doesn't have a double-sided
sofa in their home huh and don't use it
as protection during a zombie apocalypse
who doesn't do that
blings homemade now we just need cars -
and we got the best party of all time
Yas AJ find cars to look at the booth
window too small to crawl through this
is a cinema it's happening
some guy ate beans at the cinema those
are our options
it's dark in there
we should kill the monsters Thank You AJ
LM certain to yourself yes well they
used to be people and as people they
asked to be left alone disagreeing so
what's best
all right let's kill them I'll get the
key
I'm sorry
by are you mad
don't care surely stabbing someone in
the throat doesn't like if you're a
zombie I mean you don't get hit the
brain good job
sorry it had to go this way I mean you
can't die twice that's just how it is
maybe he didn't leave the keys on
yourself like a bunch of bengis oh okay
clearly we could have just gone around
and broke the window but hey yeah maybe
that was the other option he bought
thing going here
can we stay here we'll see no one's here
no one's ever anywhere it's always just
monsters can't for one to you wishes a
lot of bad people AJ be careful what you
wish for there must be good ones too
we're good that's what everyone thinks
he takes a great shine remember what we
said you know this see the last bullet
for yourself always aim for the head
that's right come on let's keep looking
there's got to be something we can eat
hope some I like them the mood of this
one it's got good atmosphere
I'll look how much food we got you're
spoiled
sorry buddy these are long gone [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] language hey watch the swears I
mean shoot yeah look it's a magnetized
bottle oh I gotta go closer here it
wouldn't be a telltale game without all
the wonkiness florid or yeah thanks to
Mordor hide something
alright alright alright alright alright
eat thank you guys we found it I mean
that's pretty good lot of stuff and
damage it is we could eat for weeks with
this much what oh no that's right
oh are you kidding me
what a bunch of Nimrods eh I could they
ah death says the No
that's too
okay shoot we need to get back to the
car
do you think the food is cooked now that
it exploded to the sides and be my eyes
Wally clear a path
all right it's clinical ooh action
thanks for waiting thanks for a
nutrition
what is this one day over here whoa are
you kidding me what happened
I know I'm dead but okay you know what
to do Alexa it'd be my eyes well a clear
path
that was not a fake
they go back up again I like how they
just wait
you know why I messed up because it says
queue and all the other time said you to
stab
make sail away let's go
[Music]
thanks for helping me that's not the
ignition don't you need the keys
are you done it now climbing
say how he still has the keys
what else
thank you are they pushing the car
what is happening what's the make out
now we can get the keys
okay just hurry up
youngsters there it is thank you
all right let's get out of here
Thank You Seto
really really
okay actually you know what it means
shoo
AJ AJ is a great shot AJ is a great shot
they said well where was that AJ
Oh someone's helping us
don't take it
[Music]
Oh what happened aging okay
a rat okay all right hey hey hey okay
all right here we are with a music event
but hopefully doesn't get claimed
[Music]
oh I got a sneeze that doesn't want to
come
sometimes I don't know
I hate that taking me sometimes I don't
know that was a thing I remember the
ending theme to your Walking Dead Season
one was so good they always had really
good music I like the art style it's
very cool
the final season begins smash like
everybody do you guys think it's me
Shawn it was that her name
really didn't like Michonne
[Music]
tear off tape wow she's good at they
damn I wish I was that good at taint
you know I'm saying
what is this place why are you talking
to yourself it's pretty it looks like
we're in some sort of hospital I keep
hitting G instead of X I mean if I
wonder one last time I took a shower
disgusting but some weirdos get off on
that why am i bringing it up I don't
know okay don't worry about it
alright I'm walking away now walking
away now from your dirty thoughts
literally okay okay all right here I go
here I go here I am what's up [ __ ]
Clemmy that [ __ ] language please
alright your demonetised in my video no
good reason [ __ ] okay now that's to
strike
oh I clicked it twice and it's my fault
we found some weed boys
okay there oh what a thigh it's gotta be
really annoying being short Ike I'm
super tall everyone online says I'm
short you got it wrong all right if you
google my high
it says 175 I am at least three meters
okay I don't know why Google is
spreading these lives like if this was
me I wouldn't need a chair the chair
would need me oh yeah find a weed box
grabs out a tool okay
game damn she's good at that
if it's if it's Kenny I this will be my
face if it's me Shawn
this will be my face okay if it's
someone else I'll be like alright that's
cool
what you suck shut up door dumb door
yeah you suck door alright well I like
said this is not epic oh my god nothing
over here shut up
Oh everything is so mean to me what did
I do
I'll kill him kill me hide in the grass
yeah yeah yeah that's good that's good
Clemmy
she's always 20 steps ahead stab him
anyone wearing those dishonor
now we're not gonna hurt you
we've got you boy he's safe if you want
to see him again you'll drop that knife
now I mean
I just wanted to show that I'm alpha I
was learning all I was doing there on a
little kid that's good see
well good here look we wanted to hurt
you we would have by now considering the
circumstances I'll let this little
standoffs lie but you only get one
strike now well what's wrong with your
face in case your boy what happened to
your fades died what's wrong with your
face do you want to fight a little truth
no please just take me to see him all
right since you asked so nicely so look
out lock on the door and Italian you to
the bed and all you were in a pretty
rough shape when we found you yeah take
precautions you know just in case a year
to live rent Harlan really bad that's
Tennessee column 10 for short he's won
been taking carrier yeah it doesn't talk
much
Clementine
come on what's happened here sir your
boy no no no no no no no I don't ship it
okay I don't ship it
no I don't ship it be quiet
[Music]
anyone with that haircut I don't it's
not good enough for Clementine that's is
that simple you've been surviving out
there a while huh yeah we've been on the
road a long time II know how to handle
yourself I usually see people our age
alone out in the wild sure I do what I
can to get by no matter what don't worry
about it we all do what we have to how
kind of kamma was that in Maine
they're all very accepting of a new
person it's good we found you when we
did wasn't easy getting you two out of
that wreck on the way the car was a
totaled yeah [ __ ] had to work fast I
don't know what would have happened if
we hadn't seen the smoke I appreciate it
all alone with the kid that's you guys
I've seen some rough scenes hi there
what's his problem you just knew we
haven't seen anything like you and ever
what is this place you can probably tell
it used to be a school now it's whatever
we want it to be and who's in charge
well I am
you probably sounds strange kids run by
kid but we do all right for ourselves
okay got good walls good defenses a good
location too
no one really comes out this way anymore
it carved ourselves the perfect camp
kids are safe here make sure of it
no adults at all how did this Cyrus like
this though people leave they die
there's less of us all around I got us a
system in place that works well enough
fine allow me to make it formal welcome
to Erickson's boarding school for
troubled youth boy feels like you both
fit that description it's hard to
survive too long these days without
being a bit hey Jay and I are angels I
was pretty good as a kid before
everything changed
made a lot of trouble since then we all
had to grow up fast I'd say that goes
double for your boy it's been a little
terror since he arrived excuse me
let's just say he hasn't been happy
without you around I need to take care
of this knowing Willie it's probably too
grandma Walker's and an angry squirrel
you got bigger fish the kids inside
Vicky's with Lewis Lewis oh right just
listen for the music you'll find him get
a move on Willie where's your damn
weapon Angie nine-year-old yeah you guys
would fit in here wouldn't you troubled
kids
and knew it f Ericsson follow the music
check we are Ericsson
[Music]
okay let's go that's probably the
teacher I'm not wearing pants
oh damn neither am i nope
music sounds like it's coming from this
floor don't care okay so in there the
game was really insinuating that we
would go upstairs language you Smurf
your little boy just bit me
yeah he's infected boot to his head
nearly took a chunk out of me hurts a
fierce he's a good kid
you must have provoked him tapping him
on the shoulder ain't provoking this is
what I get for trying to be nice to the
kid screw you both easy really infected
[Music]
clem you're okay I was afraid you were
don't worry about me
I'm not going anywhere not anytime soon
but AJ listen to me that girl out there
says you bit her yeah what the hell
answer me AJ did you bite her
I didn't mean to she snuck up on me
still no more bites no more bite you're
not dead
that's good and look it's Jaden Smith
kid for you oh my god excuse me I
watched AJ for you hope he didn't cause
you any trouble he was a bit of a
handful but I got off flight compared to
what Ruby winters stupid Jaden Smith
sneaking into everything don't ever do
it
oh ho ho loud and clear little man
thankfully I was here to calm him down
with my alluring music
I'm Lois Clementine oh this ship has
happened oh yeah totally forgot Marlin
left your bag in here somewhere
don't worry I've got it
don't worry the Sasse Clemmy yeah just
stick that up your butt oh oh is that
what I think this is so sweet
um double um does he know what that is
it's dirty clean it maybe later
back you go Ferris belongs dude
that can't be a good idea that thing's
bigger than him is it actually loaded
yes oh good I'll guarantee he's a better
shot than you hey you guys do your thing
I guess you don't know any others well
there is one but you're armed
that's my seat Thank You Apple create
new plan what do you think AJ not always
compress this key come on now give it a
try ahead AJ press it the whole place
blows up oh my god now press this one
someone's gonna be in this one yeah
you're a natural
hey you seen Rosie nope
we've got a bit of a situation out there
um to ask you're just coming to it all
but could really use a hand yup for
taking out a few dead heads you too
Louis get your ass in gear huh fine
[Music]
so what makes these guys special like
how do they get food how do they protect
themselves why is being kids somehow
better right because anywhere we've seen
Isis falling apart
good we're gonna need you to put it to
use we've got a hunting party out there
trying to get back inside you don't help
to clear the way it seems to be a few
more than usually the last couple days
it's almost like something drew their
attention something like I don't have an
explosion or a car crash bye okay bye
the SAS just saying I don't think we've
met
I'm Clementine yeah I know your kid
won't stop talking about you oh hello
Clementine I'm violet nice to meet you
what he said all right boys and girls
you're starting to fill in come on
be careful I don't mind violet she grows
on you I promise
oh this it's chair leg I call it
Jarrell's
all right he's not good enough for a
Clementine on face show officially off
the list forever I need you to watch my
back call up from inside you see
anything cool okay
see you on the other side
[Music]
[Applause]
Thanks [ __ ]
all right say suppose do you alright
pretty cool yeah you know it
[Music]
how did they get that they're all marks
so keep a lookout
why would I waste them
and we don't do it but like I can't
imagine how much effort he must have
taken I like I can choose how to kill
them
let's cut this one that cut through the
rope and your
he's got some fat logs
dude look at that that's a peg what the
Frick dude I click thing
all right you can actually die in this
game I just realized okay all right
not my fault it's not my phone all right
maybe you should really need to feel it
should be quiet well I just wanted to
see that again okay don't worry about
[Music]
why does this happen to me
one thing that always bothered me about
Walking Dead is the fact that they
merely get blood everywhere
no kidding
okay but you can never get infected from
getting like blood in your eye like
other diseases would spread I know that
would be a lame way for someone to be
infected but it just ruins the immersion
- Lal bag let's finish these guys off we
don't need them attractive imagine a
zombie movie
alright listen to level Billy all right
imagine a zombie movie where they just
do everything exactly how you want to do
it like built a pup their arms perfectly
with like duct tape or whatever they'll
use all the smart things that no one
[ __ ] thought about you know
- stupid zombies behind them all the
time where would the fun be in that it
would be awesome
instead of seeing all these people
struggle for memories holy bowls oh my
god oh that's a scary dog hey sorry
sorry damn yeah see you and Rosie are
making friends
excuse me but a bad experience with the
dog whines well Rosie here can help you
get over Jesus cuddly as they come
oh except when she's mulling walkers
that is you would have to do that right
that Walker came out of nowhere all
right all right funs over
let's get inside you're not the only one
[ __ ] language is it how hard is it go
out there how do you think it went
be nice a sim save stones nearly dry I
could barely find enough for tonight
we're gonna have to scout out further if
we want food for the winter talk about
it later
oh [ __ ] we should talk about this right
now I said later damn it
still standing I see I'd call that a
b-plus performance thereby you've done
better [ __ ] off b-minus then
now Clem here that was a solid a a-plus
even surely agriculture Milan you were
great you kicked ass violet a plus yeah
wham and power of funny what here both
delusional surely agriculture would be
the most important skill during a zombie
apocalypse cuz then you could just
harvest food and those things that you
do now you don't have to always scavenge
for cans or whatever
you you lock off an area and you never
have to leave they're pretty
good-looking monsters come on y'all
maybe an island or something like that
hey J don't know sorry thing about that
painful thing to punch at the same table
hey Jake apologize I'll talk to him
hey good job AJ hi what what are you
looking at what's that bird doing that's
gross he should stop that Birds a crow
in school they told us they're called
scavengers can you say that
yeah vet
scavengers dangers
what's it mean it means they don't hunt
like us they just eat stuff that's
already dead
scavengers are gross oh yeah I didn't
mean to hit him I didn't know that it
was Marvin Marlin right AJ I'm sure
they'll forgive you but we should go
talk to them but but I don't think they
like me trust me no one does you can
just tell hmm if they don't let's go
show them how wrong they are
I think I'll stay here with the bird
AJ listen we haven't eaten for days
the car is gone all that's outside these
walls are walkers do you really want to
go back out there no so we should
apologize to Marlon right now oh you can
work up to it let's talk to the other
kids first
how do you guys feel about this setting
on all these new characters it's pretty
interesting but you know if it was my
game I would have make it so everyone
had like perfected everything at this
point it's the last season surely these
people would understand how to survive
more than putting nails in a chair like
and call it Charles
all right let's apologize to Jason Smit
hey guys Gleb hey this is Omar excuse me
chef Omar hello and no it's not ready
yet
Omar's a perfectionist the slightest
flavor out of place and he's grumpy for
a week you can eat her you can eat right
well it'll cost you as a little patience
I'll let you guys know when we're done
here's another thing right so he's
supposed to be cooking but where are all
the ingredients like where all the foods
if he actually cared about making the
food good you did see that he do have
some stuff here I think this game misses
a lot of small stuff attention to detail
I don't know why I'm being so critical
I'm just saying all right no I want to I
want to talk to Marvin or whatever his
name was or whatever I guess we can chat
Hey
hey you know
I am carving a weapon yeah I can see
that you're good at that you like that
huh little dude
want to see something cool I want to see
stabs him in the face
whoa whoa pretty rad huh
that's I can [ __ ] up some monsters swear
I'm sorry
I would make a spear right that would
make more sense you have to get up close
and stuff just poke everyone
yeah I make a spear
see if I was in the epochal some BPAC
illegals I'd be fine yeah girl I
apologize I want to talk to her you mean
say I'm sorry yes
she's scary and always seemed so mad
yeah well you bit her you can do it you
just gotta
he just got a start with a joke once
she's laughing apologize okay
never heard that but okay let's give it
a go yes not not lose their edge and
choo bless you
I'm sorry I beat you
oh you're forgiven you little weirdo I
did it you sure did oh my god
now don't worry buddy hope you see the
mini any look we're fine
at you jokes
everybody ah
what is happening
because I have my
right no it's because I'm still touching
alright
I'm professional youtuber okay I think I
know what I'm doing alright I don't need
to hear about you and you that dog is so
scary
I'm not ready not yet
okay let's talk to someone else
alright who do you want to talk to then
you schmuck Alexa can you cast obsidian
hello hello don't copy me coming oh my
god AJ - its you - Clementine right yep
a sim right what are you writing history
I mean today my Chronicle everything
that's cool hmm like diary I try to
think of it more like a history book
those who do not learn from the past you
seemed really mad at Marlon back there
he keeps pulling back to safe zone we
have fewer and fewer places to hunt
which means we're gonna have fewer and
fewer things to eat he's trying to and
help the hunting party come back she hey
zippy very pretty
give it back it was just sitting there
so
so it was just sitting there all right
give it back AJ give it back to him okay
thank you
this thing is the only place I get any
real privacy around here you gotta
preserve what I can no I gotta finish
this before dinner not to be like food
but you know bye hahaha I like this guy
Rock'em toph Eric I Rock'em borrow much
all right you ready now are you ready no
they're not sure anyone would have
pledged to that pretty sky I do think
the game is way prettier than it's ever
been even though maybe the contrast is a
bit overdone all right what are you guys
talking about let's just pretend like
we're talking so that she goes away okay
that sounds good I like that idea yeah
me too I like that idea
I like that idea a lot more yes I like
it too
is it working has he left yet
please Debbie she's gone she's not gone
she killed a okay what are we when age
ago so I forgot my objective I got a
side trip'
Raj no well well well oh there's more
people over here okay hey guys all right
losers the emo kids knock it off ten
heard you guys didn't have the best
introduction it wasn't my fault
ten I really am sorry really
I'm sorry too what is this
our graveyard you guys still do that
kinda sorta so who is buried here
nobody really this is where we buried
ten sister's belongings Minnie and
Sophie twins Boston about a year ago
paying respects should we do that too
maybe no let them have some space okay
I'm glad you're not in a graveyard oh
thanks
go commit graveyard yeah go commit
funeral hey I got an achievement
everyone yeah I'm ready oh good good
talk tomorrow okay don't care virgin
backflips five times what just realize
Clemmy is a virgin why am I thinking
about this kind of time just saying how
old they say me he's a sweet little
fella figured they're in a lot of room
for sweetness still out there pretty
careful he bites don't worry about Ruby
from what I hear it was self-defense
oh he was talking about aging not even
realize really sorry I hate you
can we please stay here and eat dinner
and not go out into the forest and get
killed by monsters don't sweat it buddy
you can make it up to me by teaching me
your technique you regular Abbi wait hey
Clem AJ Stu's done 16 18 19
she supposed to be grown-up right
how do you think they do dishes without
water or do you think they get water
from ladies and gentlemen dinner is
served
Thanks what can't remember the last time
we had a hot meal hmm this is really
good
this boy's gonna become the next one I
wrote oh come on
hello ill hey slow it up AJ you're gonna
choke what a slob dude
just because everything else died
doesn't mean manners did I'll say
goodnight goodnight
she ain't faster than Haley I'm sorry
buddy I'm sure they shared as much as
they could
AJ heads up I'm full kiddo
you can have the rest are you sure you
bet
how fast is he eat mm-hmm me too
oh my god know what I'll tell you what
time for something very important I hope
God good night
violet it's time
what's the game tonight Lu war the
oldest game around the game played by
man and beast alike the only game there
is I don't know the game the only car
game I've played had less people don't
worry you'll pick it up as we go it's
easy everyone gets a stack of cards
everyone flips one over highest card
wins that's it winner gets to ask clam a
question
Oh what I want to get to know you
we all do and what if I win then you get
to ask us one it's only fair mmm wait
what about AJ what about it looks like
he's made a friend
sure come on you can take your eyes off
it
one card game but you both could use a
break from each other
yeah maybe this is his first time around
anyone his own age sometimes he acts
more like an adult than my kid it's nice
to see him act like a little boy again
Louis if you would
I mean clearly the odds are against us
way to go me so about AJ where AJ's
parents you don't really look related so
what happened there they're dead they
were nice people for the most part it
makes sense he's a nice kid
for the most part oh my god oh my gosh
that was that big guys Hey
all right that's a high card Hey I win
Hey you do so what do you want to know
and met anyone famous course injury
witness Marlon's hurricane yeah what's
up with your haircut Marlon oh boy
what do you mean she mean she looks like
a dead cat probably smells like one too
I look cool hmm whatever you say
I say I look cool hooyah
come on spit it out so are you single
never have a boyfriend oh my what it
happens perfectly valid question you can
ask me if I've ever had a girlfriend
I haven't by the way never not even once
never
why I win so you can't have been alone
this entire time who used to take care
of you mom [ __ ] anyone the first person
who taught me about survival was Lee
what he teach you lots of stuff most
important thing
how to shoot a gun useful stuff yeah I
taught AJ the same way too I went again
you do indeed ask away
really I don't care worst injury you
ever saw more boring than actual
McCartney so hard both his eyeballs flew
out pretty cool
I saw someone have their intestines
pulled all the way out like all the way
it goes on for a while we got a lot of
goods
victory violence here's something I love
to ask when I'm in groups out of the
four of us who do you think is gonna die
first that is [ __ ] up hmm well I know
any one of you let's certainly not me so
sure made it this far
so have we I am the greatest card player
of all time just ask your damn question
she says ever actually never mind
what ask it it's not a fun question ask
ever had to kill someone you loved oh
come on Lois
hey she wanted me to ask me his name was
Lee yeah well you're already talking to
the same day I found out my parents were
dead
sounds like a rough day worst day of my
life
I think I'm done playing for tonight
yeah it's probably for the best
you wanted me to ask
let's go AJ
good night night AJ oh he made a friend
this is so sweet
long day huh yep real long I hope you
know Luis didn't meet anyone there it's
just the world's biggest dumbass hey
he's my best friend so I can legally
call him back
let's relax get some sleep
human for a night good morning come find
me and talk about making this long-term
we can stay we can talk about it
Wow
it's always like as soon as it's super
nice those zombies oncoming it out of
nowhere you know it oh the game crash
I got no we're fine okay I think I could
do a pretty good zombie job whatever
that means boys are the zombies rising
that looks like a really safe window it
does good
oh he learned I see that's cool what if
something goes so many colors well must
have been an artist living in here
what's an artist it's like a person who
colors a lot draws does pictures you
mean Mike Tim yeah like ten huh I like
to do pictures too oh [ __ ] I didn't know
Marlon set you up in this room I just
wanted to grab something from the closet
her box what the hell is it she blind
uh what that's what I was looking for it
belonged to Sophie uh ten sister he was
asking for my art supplies and stuff so
I was going to uh sorry we didn't no no
no it's it's fine till don't worry about
it honestly it's just been sitting here
for the past year and no one's touched
it if AJ wants to play with it it's it's
fine
you should probably give the box back it
doesn't belong to us thanks buddy
it's just that 10-1 of it since it was
his sister's milk you can just keep one
thing and one paper and that's it
all right sherry you finish your drawing
though I don't mind
you Jonathan didn't know I you see your
him
settling in yeah is that okay
sure I guess I always liked this room
Sophie had like paintings and [ __ ] on
the walls lots of color and Minerva
she was really musical not like Lewis
though she had actual talent she had the
most amazing voice real bluesy marlon
always joked that he would scavenge a
guitar and the two of them would tour
the country that was a long time ago
after they afterwards Brody and ten took
down all the paintings and that was the
end of it I shouldn't have even brought
it up it's not a good memory guess I
just lost my train of thought holy sound
like they were great friends yeah sophie
was a good friend and maybe doing
something outside making the wars noise
you were close
me and her but what exactly happened to
them Sophie and Minerva
they went scavenging with Marlon and
Brody out past the safe zone didn't make
it back it happens
honestly I just miss having someone
around to talk to there's just so many
dudes this place can get a little too
bro town for my liking sometimes and I'm
not exactly like a people person you
know
I know I sometimes have a habit have a
habit of being a little bit too harsh
yeah me too
first impressions aren't exactly my
strong suit either oh right
take loom I'm an artist now oh my god
let's see a let's see it come on let's
see it shall we - not bad kiddo oh my
god I should be getting back thanks
again for the box you're pretty cool AJ
it's a shame they didn't show it see ya
mr. rebound it you know okay Alvin jr.
time for bed okay
here for me for the wall to make our
home look nice that's a good idea if you
tried really hard sure I'll just add it
with all the tape by hand how about
here's what collectible can be fun to
decorate your room okay AJ hey there
what are you doing this is where I'm
gonna sleep what no it's not it's safe
under here no one can get me come on AJ
the bed is way better what an idiot
man this bed is so comfy what about the
door what if someone comes in what if
they try to hurt us what if they still
are stuff that door is really sturdy
trust me yeah you saw another person
that try to get in she didn't even come
in I don't know if I stay here no one
can find me and I can keep guard and
watch over you I can protect us Hey
what's gotten into you
please Clem AJ listen to me it's gonna
be okay please just give the better
chance it's soft and warm I think you'll
really like it
ts bet is really soft you won't remember
that it's okay really soft
good night AJ how long do you think
he'll remember that the bed is soft mmm
this place is nice
I'm glad we found it me too yeah pretty
good deal actually could be worse I mean
considering they're they literally were
on the foot no food or nothing
[Music]
he's gonna let us stay right
I guess we're gonna find out let's find
his office I know where it is I'll show
you how do you know all right
do you think you can say yes come on
come this way
hey AJ wait up what if it candy is the
principle that would be epic I would be
sincere I want like a moment you know
hey Clem what up Dawg for the pencils I
missed having colors yeah sure thing
who are these guys they are firefighters
Godwin was a policeman
she's gonna save the day but what are
they they these were the people who
protected us where are they yeah where
were they you know what happened you
already know what happened to them they
weren't strong enough no that's not true
they were super strong yeah the kids
totally yeah no he's mine hey AJ you got
an attitude error
you don't even know what they are okay
okay that's enough you two it's not
yours anymore it's mine
no it's not why did you learn nothing
from yesterday thanks
[Music]
or do you know where Marlin is sure I
don't know he should be around I can go
find him that'd be nice thanks 10 look
hey what'd you find it's a picture of
Marlon and Luis
there's so little Wow yeah they've known
each other a long time huh Marlon Marlon
changed oh my god what happened to you
he said dogs brought back bad memories
sorry scared
well it was I swear barking and I'm
striving as she seems
yeah I'm white barrier oh my girl I
could care our dog see she's harmless
she just needs to get to know you is all
how to comb part at night John yeah
I'll show you
do you trust me yes okay I guess get
down on her level get yourself it's okay
go whistle tell her to lie down look at
this guy's
lie down Rosie that's so cool
see yeah I know it's hard that was
pretty cool
now Rosie will recognize you she's
really well trained just like Edgar
she was the Headmaster's dog back when
this place was still functional
but when the world went to [ __ ] he
bailed all the other adults did left us
behind to fend for ourselves
really Wow what a dick yeah
understatement of the century
now it's just us kids left and I'd like
it if you and AJ were part of that both
of you were plenty capable and we need
that here this is the current state of
our plan for gathering food master of
ass yesterday we are starting to run
short it's getting harder and harder to
feed everyone in this school yeah so
you're welcome to say thank you that
makes sense
[Music]
I don't know
that's the train station there was a
whole stash of food under the
floorboards
don't worry crash your car pretty sure
that place of lost cause I handle a lot
of smoke coming from when we found you
two walkers flooded in there after all
the noise you made it well we can't
check in what's out here oh that's where
we fish I got fat for storage right here
right along the river it's secure mostly
we get the occasional walker to come by
vine Brody should be heading up there in
a bit
[Music]
that's the only road that leads in and
out of Ericsson you go off it you'll
eventually end up in the valley
you just have sides that let people to
the school but I took them down wanted
this place to be hard to find it that's
pretty good
what's the trap area right next to your
legs
Lewis builds some traps out there to
catch game he and a Sam are set to go
check them today
[Music]
I didn't realize how much forest
surrounds this place it's how we've kept
ourselves from unwanted attention for so
long
Oh for the most part anyway
greenly have a greased house oh yeah
well don't get too excited about that
one
we used to maintain it real well plenty
of vegetables growing but it became
overgrown
keep was possible y-yeah yeah we keep
away from that now you could sort it out
dude one more thing
see these red lights yeah everything
inside isn't safe so it's me getting
smaller over the years and the foods
become more scarce so why not go outside
it whenever someone goes outside the
safe zone bad [ __ ] happens people die or
disappear
I just mmm I can really use the help
Clement I'm taking care of these kids
it's not easy I'm worried that if I
don't figure something out if I don't
fix our food situation I can't lose
anyone else we've already lost so much
friends siblings I I get it
I know how it feels to lose a friend
yeah well multiply that by 30 you know
how I feel what ha sorry
everyone's counting on me to step up be
the leader they need me to be I really
want to be that for them you and AJ are
two more mouths to feed maybe he can
help me feed the rest so what do you
need from us Luis and a sim are heading
to the hunting grounds looking for
rabbits well a sim will anyway Louis
just don't be shows up if I'm really
being honest violet and Brody going
upriver to do some spearfishing
hopefully I was to get along long enough
to get some work done both teams could
use some extra hands let's go do some
hunting yeah take this I don't want you
getting lost Thanks
you need all hands on deck if we're
gonna find like such a complicated area
just remember to stay in the safe zone
we need you to come back home in one of
these so that means we'll get to stay
what do you think I was gonna throw you
out
maybe well as long as we got enough to
eat both welcome here go get him AJ oh
all right let's get going
it'd be funny if AJ didn't know what a
hi-fi was see you around yeah this
episode hasn't been going on for a while
I'm just gonna go hunting as well I
wonder what the differences if you
choose hunting or fishing hunting
grounds are usually clear of walkers
sometimes they get caught in the snares
and [ __ ] though you see a ribbon on a
tree traps or nearby so watch where you
step okay please I think I can handle
myself
I'm basically a ninja he's skilled in
the craft of martial arts all right
thanks for the head for the warning
careful around those okay okay yeah I
know fun we got work to do not all of us
have the privilege of being Marlins
lapdog
oh ouch someone's a little jealous and
my defense I totally get things done I
just prefer to think of survival is more
of a day-to-day task so you know don't
sweat the technique what about everyone
else we need to work together as a team
I mean sure yeah sometimes you act like
you're the only one with a strategy I
play the long game you gotta have plans
B C and D and what if you don't make it
that far
shut up a second
what is that whoa what is that what is
that that was huge
damn it I thought thought something
interesting would happen yeah I thought
it would be like a giant zombie or
something like that would be so cool
he's like a walker pinata to fix the
smear and let's go oh well I will
eventually if you want food for the kid
I could use a hand or you can mess
around with this idiot and start man
killing zombies must be so fun oh you
can see I've somatic
all right let's come on wanna take a
swing it won't bite well that guy would
but the bat won't you know what I mean
no maybe in a bit all right suit
yourself I don't want to make a bad
impression I just got here come to hunt
I hear something rustle around in here
yeah let me help you out for a second
arrow is worried you're gonna encourage
him I'll never understand that idiot
a seem well remembered you good shot
yeah good I'll chase him out of the bush
you shoot last time I was out here
looked like one of the rabbits have some
babies I'm not sure how many are still
around so careful where you shoot aim
for the parents aims for the [ __ ] kill
it
yeah I don't worry about it better to
save our arrows anyway I saw some others
run this way I really thought I had it
dude you Sam still got them
you definitely nailed the thing did you
just put in his pocket
look it gauntlet Oh
it's a baby well all meat is good meat
it's not a knife a baby so why to get
bigger oh okay so am i but we'll be even
hungrier tomorrow if we don't let him go
tomorrow doesn't exist dingus
there's just today and today I'm hungry
we're hungry are you gonna do it I can't
watch
is that a bad idea I can't tell by bunny
really what are we supposed to eat
tonight then uh I get it I wouldn't want
to kill a baby bunny either you'll thank
me in a few months if we live that long
all right well the snares have all been
reset and are ready to trap things we
good to go now or what and what does he
want to do some bad things I'll take
this back you two should meet up with
Brody and violet and see if they've
managed to snag any fish this isn't
gonna be enough for the whole school
I like fish that's great
see ya follow me the girls are probably
near this hey hey that's great I once
ate a whole shark no you didn't oh man
that was hilarious this guy
where's vine birdie they should be here
by now
Oh No Clem look
monster told you spare spíritus grain
see what cysteine wait isn't that one of
our Spears take it
clémence locks busted we might not be
alone get the spear all right I want to
see some gangsta shooting from AJ like
tilted hood shot it's clear holy [ __ ]
this place is wrecked all of our
supplies are gone I'll take a look
around outside hold tight
what happened are we in danger maybe
cigarette hand-rolled is a Bible page
Clementine what's happening here what
the hell happened in here do any of the
kids smoke nope
nothing to smoke no sign of our thief
thief oh [ __ ]
we just walked a mile of river and the
traps were all empty no fish
none someone robbed us oh great and now
we're gonna start [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
just it's okay it's breathe bro come on
come on come on come on you're gonna be
fine take a second breathe in deep and
hold it just shut the [ __ ] up okay
excuse me hey I have to tell Marlon
about this we still need food you know
to live we definitely don't have enough
here you guys figure it out so what do
we do eat rocks you can't eat rocks I'm
aware so Marlon kick us out if we don't
find food well let's not find out where
else could we look let me think outside
the red zone I think don't go here yeah
it's not too far from here I don't know
that's pretty far outside our perimeter
there was food in there when AJ and I
passed through it's worth a look sure
there was food positive yeah some of it
was destroyed the explosion but there
has to be something left there was so
much there all right fine lead the way
I'm sure the food is cooked as well you
know multiband very good the cook I cook
with on grenade
well this is probably not gonna go well
walkers than last time now
oh dude leafy it's either die here or
dive in longer take your pick
come on maybe you should scope things
out you know the place better let me get
a closer look
can't be too careful
I climb up there I don't know how that
would get us inside need to get in there
somehow maybe there's another way in you
barely got out of here it was close it
sounds scary there's a reason it's like
a really bad idea to get the Walker's
attention they do like to follow sound
you look like you've got an idea
the noise from that Bell could draw a
lot of walkers if one of us climbs up
there and starts ringing it Louis Ivo
Louis this is way too dangerous
I'd like to make an alternate suggestion
you loud dramatic a little annoying I
think out all right I see how it is I'll
go with you give you some cover okay
this convene just don't do it but I died
I'm making sure Walker Lewis eats both
of you first I'll distract them until I
see you guys reach safer cover then I'll
try to redirect the smelly Patrol to
give you guys a chance to sprint inside
the building when we get into position
I'll signal you then you can do your
thing good luck
also if you have a place like this and
they're attracted to noise couldn't you
set up like traps that are sound based
like if you get in oh oh yeah I have to
kill these guys these didn't really work
he's really good at that
the place does meseta everyone can
what is he waiting for
ruing is over just give him a second me
not have a separate arrows everybody
okay
let's make it
Scot they really improve the camerawork
it's really cool how it flows this is
dead that's no way because I saw like I
should have given the option to kill it
hey guys hey guys you're back you're
back all right
yes these will be perfect once look what
is it try it out see if it works
not now not now we're here for food
gonna need your help on this one kiddo
everyone knows everyone knows a wooden
floor protects just any grenade blast
do they got some mushroom soup the soup
sub soup
good job EJ is there more keep it coming
what is this time
he's got banana names okay this is epic
all right bad thing will happen in three
two one stand don't try anything thank
God hey it's a thief I had the power of
God an enemy on my side what do you want
I just want food same reason you're here
you and your friends made a lot of noise
out there it wasn't hard to follow
you live close by you knew about this
place already and organized some effort
to get inside
I've seen those cigarettes before you
messed up our traps didn't you guilty as
charged
when it was an honest mistake I could be
a real Butterfinger sometimes
you look a little young to be out on
your own you got a group no that was
kind of me you know plus the two outside
I'm thinking maybe more
we're a big group strong people
well-armed right and this big strong
group sends the kids out to do the risky
work interesting
I'll fill this pack real slow we worked
hard to get this stuff
why hey there squirt playing
hide-and-seek are we
oh that's impolite
don't steal from us I'm not stealing
this isn't yours
at mckeil
I'm kid I'm faster than you listen up
squirt
you're gonna quit pointing that gun at
me and let me go bye Mary
you understand I'm just gonna take a
little bit then I'm leaving
like it never happened AJ lowered the
gun Klim he's stealing our phone Alvin
jr. now don't trust this kid with a gun
I really don't why is Wilma Clem we're
running out of time we need to get out
don't panic I was just leaving
thanks for dinner
who when the [ __ ] was that just take it
back and fill it up
[Music]
okay
ever feeling we're gonna run into that
guy later
Marlon listen to me I am Telling You the
place was ransacked it's fine we'll deal
with it why can't everyone help our
patients
assume that chickpeas check it out food
that's like a lot of fluid observant as
ever Mitch I can't believe this
look at it you are Savior Clem but
seriously it's a lot
Lewis and violet helped to either of
them ever brought back this much before
neither where did you find all this the
old train station clam new where was
train station that's outside the safe
zone Wow thank you so much but we ran
into the creep that [ __ ] up our fish
traps creep what creep Clem sir I'm
smoking those nasty-ass Bible cigarettes
he knows hands your different colored
eyes yeah she knows him did he follow
you no I let him have some food and then
we lost track of him in a swarm of
walkers you just let him take our food
what the [ __ ] now he knows we're out
here and he'll come back for more
what the hell were you thinking this is
[ __ ] if I hadn't done what I did he
would have shot us I made the right call
[ __ ] what if there are others you
don't know what people are capable of
out there think again I just can't I
won't just not again she fired it she
took him outside the safe zone they saw
someone you know what that means
nothing just means there's a hungry guy
out there looking for food it's happened
before you are overreacting
you can't be serious come on let's go
somewhere and talk about this
dude if anything happens I'm holding you
responsible what's her deal Clem thank
you for for help did you did but uh-huh
[ __ ] yeah I think cz
no one died you don't have to worry
we're you tonight I always do though I
can't help it
haha well look we got the beans eating
tonight for the next few I'd wager um
I'll go talk to Brody thanks for the
haul Clem you guys should go enjoy
you've earned it
well he cooks fast this time I thought
that way ever since we lost Sophie and
Minnie already has been freaked out by
anything that happens pass the safe zone
she'll be all right eventually still we
should make sure this is a one-time
thing we can take Rosie out in the
morning see if she catches a scent you
know just in case yeah
why don't they hunt with the dog I'm
gonna go clean up I think I'll go too
see you later
don't worry about them and they're just
sad sad why my sister's died around this
time last year I think it's starting to
get to people doesn't it get to you
not really dying's not scary I mean it's
sad but not scared you've been in here
too long when you see more death you'll
be a lot more afraid of it or maybe a
lot less that's a good point I try not
to focus on them being gone I like
picturing where they'd be now instead
oh so awesome it means tough she'd build
a place big enough for all of us to live
and paint it - and many be playing
whatever new song she wrote that's mean
I guess that doesn't scare me because I
know I have something waiting on the
other side did you say group you see
night all of us together looks like a
nice place to wind up yeah I think so
too
a lot better than some smelly old school
you're the one that's mine you know that
right the walkers who killed them you
want them all they weren't always
walkers wherever this place is everyone
gets to be a person again
oh they drive the walkers the way they
probably looked sometimes I draw Minnie
and Sophie the way they probably left
them but sometimes I draw this - can can
I be there
sure
you want to be there to know nah-nah-nah
date I promise I'll tell you well sure
why not sure
oh my god can something happens please
that's cute
here you go it's yours
oh the point is that we put in our room
okay I got it
tenants got some real talent wow it's
getting late like an art degree wasn't
useless ready to sleep aren't you coming
not yet I want to finish this first
good night see you tomorrow
sorry but how long is this episode
they always ended on a cliffhanger but I
don't know how they can end this I'm
getting a little hungry okay it's clear
what about the lamb time for bed little
guy can I stay up nope two more minutes
okay - mommy what you lay down and then
we'll see you full from dinner yeah it
was good yeah it was I wonder what the
wife would we gotta go honey and there
was so many rabbits - shoo
it's nice not driving everywhere or
running away but the ranch was nice too
before the blood this isn't the ranch
it's not bad that do you like it I like
it know that I'm used to it
it's good for now but place has changed
so do people it might not stay good been
here two days all right it's over
thinking Clem
yeah you let that mean man go at the
station
let him take food from us it wasn't
right what he did was it didn't like it
don't be mad at me for saying that
though him getting away with a little
food kept things from getting violent
you have to know when to fight AJ and
this wasn't the time it's still not
right to let someone take from us makes
us soft that's true actually I like your
philosophy aging who's mr. softie now
that's what I thought there you got a
stay up two minutes more time for sleep
I'll lay down when you blow out the
light all right give me a minute
you need a minutes of blood and light
what's happening you can now place
collectibles for your room all right we
got this paintings why there that's a
good drawing
he's a good artist your picture is good
too all I know
no I don't care
I'm not sleepy liar
that's gotta sting
good night sleep tight don't let a
walker bite and if they try I never let
him bite come on play it right one try
hey let him buy it work
bang bang bang well look at his hair it
looks crazy I think I okay what is
happening that creepy sir I think I
understand what the problem is with
these Walking Dead and is that they
constantly just introduce new characters
all the time like all the time and we
have to start from zero all the time the
only character we care about is
Clementine so really we know nothing's
gonna happen about there there's no
suspense there's no feeling of oh my god
what's gonna happen Shh they need to
keep the characters going you know make
you invested longer like one character
two characters we only really have
Clementine oh I didn't need like yeah
this is an interesting setting I know we
will get better as episodes go but it's
annoying having to start from zero all
the time I think someone's in trouble
is it us no no not right now but we
should help them if it's a monster we
should kill it I don't think it is but
we might still have like your gun aha
I'll be right back
stay safe
all right let's check it out
all right what do you guys think is up
there
follow the noise
just a little farther here it's come
from basement
[Music]
this locks from both sides I'm sure
there's gonna be something to find
another way to the basement a cellar
door out the yard I would not have
walked this way to get over there took
our dare that's try it I'm from the
country sand countryside everybody
honey according to the map should be
another entrance to the basement around
here
maybe I'll be here
wrong way alright sorry
[Music]
there it is
a lot of games always do this you pick
up the item before you know what you
need to use it for
[Music]
I don't think you can break that just
with a break they don't hear that yeah
that wasn't that loud
[Music]
show yourself hi guys what are you doing
down here
in the dark Rudy and I were just talking
go get some sleep
deserves some shut-eye you had a busy
day you're not getting rid of me that
easily tell the others what please this
is a private conversation okay it
doesn't concern you
the man you met at the station we got
history roadie tell us into a clam she's
acting crazy it's better if we have this
way sometimes you just got to knit out
let her speak [ __ ] excuse me I want
to hear what she has to say how do you
know that guy
Marlon let him take the twins him in his
peeps
sisters I thought they were killed by
walkers
that's the story we told everyone stop
cuz Marlon was so ashamed
whoa she dead
oh no I mean oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah these get interesting all
right all right all right I get away
from away from her they mean it Marlon
step back okay okay just just stay with
her there's a first-aid kit out to
someone right first aid kit
it's me Clint
just just stay still I can't see
Clementine remember your danger you and
a table full what danger nor a little
kill me if I tell he's scared
when he's scared he gets angry well good
you may I promise you that
yeah yeah you will you're strong and
he's not
if those readers coming back Milan said
he'd let him take you take us till they
come go away like he did like he did ten
sisters Rudy
oh [ __ ] she died [ __ ] No
how am I gonna do she's good
really thin I could force it in there
and lift up the latch my painter find it
in this dark man climb things were
really smart
and don't rush don't rush take your time
I could run before I can't run now think
she turned already
yeah there's a jump-scare coming
does work
three-two-one
[Applause]
hold
[Music]
[Applause]
you can't
[Music]
II
[Applause]
and she did not deserve it the worse
when you have a bad day thank you for
that game thank you for that I
appreciate that
oh that's cool the flashlight shows
blood all right you can go in two hours
straight
where is she she's in the basement she
murder of God I done justice
on your face
why broody did you see it happen is she
a walker now you killed Brody you hit
her so hard her head split open
that's a lie I saw you killer
look at her heads she's covered in
Brody's blood
Jesus Christ laughs did you do
we save their lives but anyone else
would have kept walking
but then we kept them warm and this is
how they thank us guns be folded morally
Christ
shoot me what do you offer up to your
Raider friends when they come knocking
what the hell is she talking about
because he needs us a lot Bodie told me
Marlon was gonna give me an aging up to
braiders in exchange for safety
Sophie and Minnie oh my gosh let her
talk
come the [ __ ] on they only met up with
these Raiders because Clem insisted they
go out there quite the coincidence isn't
it
shame leaving those first thing she did
was attack you 10 about how scared we
all were when the adults left
I pulled us out of that beer I gave us
some courage again
who are you all gonna believe huh
johnny-come-lately in her little [ __ ]
lunatic for me
she did help us get food what good is
food if a group of outsiders just gonna
come along and take it
I'm just saying have to believe me
you don't you met her like two days ago
damn it
she got me there
I'm sorry
this isn't like I know you're not weak
don't let her get in your head Hey
she was my friend too
so spread
clem I
Wow straighter it will all feel safer
once I pull this trigger you were there
that day those Raiders came he would
have abandoned you too
that was it that's all I needed all
right cool all right there you go Oh
violet being difficult
why am I not surprised put down the gun
now
we're gonna do this the right stand down
one be reasonable
oh okay
okay
you don't understand at all do you
whoa did you see the protect anyone
Brody's dead I made the right call
I saved the lives of everyone in this
bucket school they came back I do it
excuse me I didn't realize it was so
[ __ ] expended Jim told me they died
Oh
oh they had to save the rest of you okay
gave my sister's away why would you do
something like that I trust in you Arlen
they trusted you
he did the wrong thing but he thought it
was for the right reason
I wanted to get them States some kind of
rescue honest analysis could
I was it's too great you killed Brody
because she knew
it didn't mean to you don't accidentally
kill someone I wanted to save all of you
from yourself
I mean don't do that but I mean that
would be the
we can make this right
we're all family here too way the only
one any of us has left do way
painful things no I can't rate you let
me leave
I never have to see me again just let me
become a bad memory another one
just give me back
please
fine
all right I'm an aging
what was that net supposed to do damn I
ain't with a head now
alright Iran Iran Iran Iran our rat done
running episode 1 episode 1 you and 58%
of other period players kill the Walker
couple in the train station 42% of
players are a bunch of pie alright
alright alright what else do we got you
and 48% of players went hunting 52% of
plays went fishing coz 52% are a bunch
of birds 6 is 6 percent of players can
means 80 to sleep in the bed 34% said
sleep under the bed because they're a
bunch of bad parent not me son holy heck
he's that's a big forehand okay so
probably here everyone's gonna be mad at
me this is how you know because I you
know 20 presenter producer any food okay
78 percent attacked okay six six little
players turn to violet for help against
Marlins alright that's cool
and there we go she's feeling guilty
[Music]
heartbroken
helpless what is this why are they
adding new stuff now
[Music]
these are all the things they remember
take care interesting concept they're
really changing things all around oh
okay
all right I don't know what my feelings
are about this one I'm not amazed I'm
not like I don't think it's Lamy there
there's some cool new addition sums that
I think needs to build upon to become
cooler like the whole concept of the
school and how it changes seems like a
good idea
strange choice for the last season but
we'll see where it takes us hope you
guys enjoyed watching this playthrough
episode one I'll be sure to play the
other ones and I think you guys so much
for watching
coming soon it says when is that usually
they have a date or something
oh well that's it for me for now I see
you guys goodbye